moi je suis embêté parce que quand
j'écoute certaines personnes j'ai
l'impression de vivre au far-west quoi
n'est ce pas ce que le mot natif ce mot
là j'ai l'impression de voir le film
avec leonardo dicaprio avec new york où
il ya deux communautés qui se mettent
sur la tronche et le premier survivra
bank of new york du score c'est merci
voilà donc film très sûr très
intéressant la mention j'apprécie moi
aujourd'hui je viens du 93 j'habite le
93 j'habitais quartier comme on dit et
c'est pas du tout le ressenti que j'ai
moi j'ai été victime un jour de racisme
il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça d'un
blanc gérard blanc en tous les cas qui
me disent ah le portugais
retourne dans ton pays bon d'accord
c'est un raciste pour moi si tu les vois
les gens prennent en compte il ya un
contexte tout de suite après la
demi-finale de coupe faim la finale de
coupe d'europe où les français ont perdu
face aux portugais alors donc à défaut
d'abord avant d'être raciste il est
surtout un trou du cul du en face de moi
lorsque pour un match de foot se faire
insulter et nous dire de retourner dans
mon pays je trouve ça ridicule c'est
cumulables un mois je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est difficile de faire
peut-être une différence le racisme
c'est le royaume des cons apprenons à
vivre ensemble apprenons de des uns et
des autres parce qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de choses qui nous
rapprochent qui ne sait pas on lit dans
un pays qui s'appelle la france il ya
des citoyens qui vivent en france
lançant des citoyens je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les français s'attendent
à d'autres discours à d'autres débats
qui permettront peut-être de mieux
avancer dans la vie de favoriser leur
vide de remplir leur frigo de pouvoir
mieux travailler parce que ça c'est des
discussions c'est pas le jour des
gérants sont légères l'avocat du diable
si non mais c'est pas la direction de
saison le sax il dans les katas et se
fait traiter de sale blanc quand en plus
ils entendirent mais y'a pas de problème
ya pas de racines ils vont tous ensemble
embrassons demain mais si on attendra
sans nous les uns les autres je vais
dire ça me rend dingue les gens
je te dis pas je te dis pas je te dis
juste que peut-être ya une
méconnaissance de part et d'autre des
uns et des autres sans se lancer dans
l'ue on ne sait plus vivre ensemble puis
georges des kebabs où il ya des blancs
tu vas dans différentes régions de
france parce que là je viens de faire le
tour de france j'ai fait huit étapes en
france il ya des kebabs qui sont tenus
par des blancs parce qu'il n'ya pas de
communauté arabo-musulmane black ou
autre comme d'anr est d'accord y'a pas
d'un moment donné voilà c'est pareil tu
vois japonais c'est que des chinois un
moment des justes arrêtons ce genre de
cas apprenons à vivre ensemble on a des
débats aujourd'hui qui monopolisent qui
monopolise les médias mais qui préoccupe
pas et qui monopolise pas la visite à ce
monsieur de lyon par exemple approchons
ces messieurs de lyon ça m'intéresse ce
monsieur de lyon s'est fait agressé par
une bande de trou du cul d'accord qui
ont fait proféré des insultes racistes
qui doivent être punis d'accord de par
leurs insultes et de par leur agression
mais aujourd'hui elle est ce que
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on est capable de
remonter des chiffres qui va nous donner
un peu court s'il ya une majorité de
black qui sont prendre plein la gueule
ou si une majorité de blancs qu'ils en
prennent plein la gueule essayons comme
disait bernard de combattre tout ça
parce que pour l'instant avec ce genre
de débat on est surtout en train de
faire le lit de zemmour